welcome to LED live the show where we
use the light of Christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today and we are coming to the end of
2019 guys we've been doing the show for
seven months
but open content oh yeah for sure we've
talked about everything from topics to
popular movies to even full-on
theological discussions and a lot of you
have been along for the ride from since
the beginning and we thank you so much
for your support from watching videos to
commenting on them having discussions
with us from buying our merch Mikey is
representing right now sending us gifts
as well we just thank you for each and
every contribution and the love that
you've shown to us and this LED light
episode is no different than the rest we
are hitting some some tough trendy
topics and I have a question for you
guys okay my my Big Brother's how far
would you go where do you go how far
would you go to protect your family find
out on this episode of LED live
[Music]
so this week there was a trending
hashtag on Twitter and it was called
r.i.p Nick Cannon and when I said I was
like oh man did he die like did you guys
see the trend I didn't see the trend no
see you saw nothing about it I mean I've
just random here and there I see the
whole thing about there's a battle
between em and em and they can't in it
it was trending for days and it's
actually supported of fans of Eminem
that started it and it's so hilarious
actually is that they spelt in their
cannons name wrong instead I think so
[Laughter]
yeah instead of CNN no n is just ca n o
n so so that was pretty funny but that's
in response to a diss track that and the
cannon put out directed towards Eminem
this has actually been like a 10 year
feud between the two of them well it's
actually surrounded by one person can
you guess who both people are hi
about Nick Cannon's girl or girlfriend a
wife girlfriend true yes Mariah Carey
that's about what yeah how it started is
eminem says that he dated Mariah Carey
back in the early 2000s and Mariah
denies it
so Eminem didn't really like that very
much so he went to I mean he's a rapper
so he went and took to his music and
said some things about Mariah and by
this time Nick Cannon had married Mariah
so of course he's taking it personally
and mccannon he's Dowling rap but he's
not really known for being a rapper he's
more of a comedian and a you know
talk-show host and an actor as well in
his own right he just tipped to his blog
and took shots at Eminem Mariah went
ahead and actually made a whole song in
defense of herself have you guys listen
to obsessed do you guys remember that
song
yeah years past and this has been going
for a while and mmm recently was on a
song with Fat Joe and he took shots at
Mariah again now in Nick Cannon is like
okay I'm actually gonna release a song
he did not release just one but two diss
tracks targeted towards I'm numb he also
took shots at his family now if there's
one thing that any Eminem fan knows is
that Eminem has this this policy don't
talk about my family well so take shots
back and we see this and past beefs that
he had with other people where it's
popular opinion that he pretty much
destroyed his attackers
now we're not gonna go and read lyrics
and his posts and stuff cuz that's not
really for the show and appropriate in
any way but the topic itself explanatory
that you weary of if you look at those
battles mm-hmm but the topic itself was
interesting and I kind of want to expand
it not just talking about verbal attacks
against people's families but also
physical attacks just attacks in general
and the question is you know what what
do you do as a Christian as a Christian
man who has a family how far would you
go to protect your loved ones it's
interesting like in the public like
these people live very public lives so
you know it's not something that you
just I mean the way I would solve it
would be go straight to the person you
know kind of take the Matthew 18
approaching hey you know this is this is
this is something that I disagree with
but in the public like you know they're
releasing like things that are tied to
their record labels and all of this I
think fuels people I mean I you know
these battles have made people more
famous ya know it's just I don't maybe
not in a biblical sense but at least
they're doing it through art instead of
just really battling each other and
really right you got to wonder if this
is for promotion right right like if
something popular is coming out so they
want to get people talking about them
already right
controversy right off the bat like you
said I was actually unaware that Nick
Cannon was even in the music industry I
mean I've always seen him as a host or
something on TV so for him to to you
know this maybe puts him on the map as
an artist I don't know you know it
doesn't people hated the traction so
there's this expectation from the world
that Christians should just sit back and
take it you know and exactly and it goes
hand in hand with the idea that
Christians are soft or push over so
people can walk all over Christians what
do you guys think about that you know
there's a lot of attack towards
Christians but if you just look at the
basis of what Christianity is and
supposed to be about I mean we do preach
a turn-the-other-cheek message so I
think you know if you if you want to be
christ-like I don't know if necessarily
like battling it out publicly would be
considered in the in the theology of
what it means to be a Christian I don't
know little tough alone you know cuz
I've always wondered that myself like
should I have a gun for self-defense or
if somebody breaks in my house am I
supposed to turn the other cheek or I
mean this is really kind of
controversial it's true about 70% of
Americans own guns sorry about 70% of
Americans who own guns own it for
self-defense for protection and you know
parents send their kids for martial arts
trainings and I know for me my family
has encouraged me to actually get a
Taser because I'm living on my own in a
different state from them so they have
their their concerns as well and you
know there are a plethora of Bible texts
that with God promising to protect his
people not just from spiritual attacks
but from physical attacks as well but
yet we hear in the news and in the media
about attacks and actually deaths that
actually seem a little bit that could
have been prevented if the people were
more equipped to defend themselves look
look at the story of Peter when they're
in the Garden of Gethsemane I mean he
clearly whips out a sword and chops off
the ear of the high priests servant
right so even Jesus Lou
you did but think about it in terms of
why would you carry the sword then you
know I mean like cut some sticks down or
I mean it's the tool right I guess I
mean with a sword yeah it's hard to it's
hard to say maybe that's because you're
Bradley
you know maybe it was a pocket knife
thing it's true like people are taking
action but the Bible has texts that
advises so you know leave it up to God
in that sense but are these texts being
misinterpreted or even miss applied I
think it's hard to understand the
cultural you know like what like where
we would carry around a pocket knife
because we like whittling with wood or
something like that you know what I mean
it's like years of translation and all
sorts of you know differences of how we
need to carry around a knife today or
something isn't quite as a necessity as
maybe it was back then so it's like for
us to where we're applying it to the way
that we think about those things today
it's hard to kind of get a sense of what
was it really like for the Hebrew life
you know that lived out of the cities
who knows okay well let's bring it back
to today if either if you were in either
of these two artists positions and
someone has you know taken to art it's a
music and send sense direct shots
against you and your family talking
about your wife and also your children
which is exactly what and it can and did
I'm just curious what how would you guys
respond have you ever thought about
these things as parents as husbands one
thing I kind of like to do and it works
is to you know return evil with good
kill them with kindness type of thing so
any time in the past I've and this is
even before I was a Christian it's just
a technique that works but if somebody's
like upset with you you just kind of be
like chill about it and it's just kind
of like I don't know it kind of makes
them angrier but then it kind of
diffuses it too and I would say maybe
you know if something like that happened
to me I would probably just make a
response video or something I'd just be
like this
really amateur you know we should handle
this like man and she got some problems
let's talk about it I mean to make a
song blasting on my children that's kind
of weak you know it's kind of below the
belt I just put it like that probably
yeah I agree with you I think we did
approach that individual and and you
know you were to forgive them and love
on them like you said it would probably
cease from that point to balloon into
something else you know whereas if you
just do a public shaming back you know
it could go back and forth and then it
could be like you know well you do this
in this business in your ministry and
blah blah blah and then it could just
get kind of him out of hand where I
think in Nick Cannon and Eminem's case
if literally Nick Cannon were to go to
Eminem and be like I Love You Man you
know like like this is not right and you
know let's figure out how to get past
this or whatever like this you probably
wouldn't go anywhere it would cease at
that point
how could you continue to hate on this
yeah I mean em would be continuing to
release things against him or or vice
versa if you did that so I think kind of
like publicly making a diss track or
something like that it's throwing
gasoline on the problem so so the
question how does a Christian man
reconcile being a protector of his
household with also leaving vengeance
for the Lord many believe that they're
justified in their actions because it's
a response to or wrong you know an eye
for an eye like Exodus 21 is saying but
I've learned that how you do something
matters just as much as what you do
right so there's a right and a wrong way
to do anything really and god I feel
like God has no problem with us
defending ourselves
it's a how we defend ourselves that he
pays P intention to take Romans 12 into
consideration right it says do not
overcome by evil but overcome evil with
good which is what you brought up Mikey
so it's telling us to overcome like we
should be doing these things but do it
in such a way that is good and that
glorifies God and but the question is
what does that look like you know what
what does glorifying God in a situation
where there's a lot of tension
like and I have some scenarios that I
want to throw at you guys and maybe you
can you can help the viewers like
real-life things that have been actually
day-to-day write about this stuff a lot
yeah right rather it be bowling or
whatever you exactly fight breaks out
yeah people deal with getting dissed all
the time mm-hmm so I have three here
here's the first one let's go back to
middle school okay okay
if you see your little brother get
punched in the face on the playground
now this is one of three incidents where
older student hurts him how do you
respond one of three incidents like this
is a third times exactly so you are the
older brother in this situation and
you're seeing your younger brother being
punched and hit on I would definitely
defend him in the way of removing him
from any more physical altercations you
know I would try as best as possible to
stop the situation from progressing into
something where someone could get hurt
you know I I probably wouldn't
necessarily engage in a fight and start
throwing blows you know back at them and
definitely try to verbally talk it out
but yeah I mean I have no problem
jumping in the middle of something like
this and stopping it and separating it
you know Keith I'd like to bring up
martial arts in that there's a way to
fight someone without actually fighting
someone kind of like - what is it later
on them right exactly they throw a punch
and you're able to not get hit and also
restrain them in such a way that they
actually stop do you think that training
is good for parents to enroll their
young people in or I think there's a
term for that called tap out you know
make them on the ground no I don't and
people probably hate on me for this but
being in it observing it coming out of
it you the thing that I always tell
people is martial arts training is
inconsistent with martial arts
philosophy so philosophy is you know try
not to hurt people do everything you can
to get away from being in a fight you
know
and you know in kungfu they you know
there's like a hierarchy you know you
know MAME before crippled before
kill you know this kind of thing but
when you're training even I remember in
my earliest lessons I mean you're
learning how to break a neck right off
the bat well you know it's blocked a
punch wrap the neck snap you know I mean
you're that's what you're training for
so if you're training to do that and
you're training based off of a reaction
it's the first thing that you're going
to do because it's it's like that muscle
memory it's that reflex somebody throws
a punch you just you just start moving
and you could easily you know bust
somebody's arm you know hyperextension
bust the knee hyperextension you know
and these are injuries that take I mean
they can affect somebody for the rest of
their life and if you if you're training
to kill somebody you know and you're not
it's you because when somebody is going
to throw a punch or a kick at you you're
not sitting there going hmm I wonder
what I should do you know use this you
just start moving and so the next thing
you know somebody's on the ground
they're hurt they're injured worst case
scenario you know they're dead you you
are supposed to if you are if you're a
black belt you're supposed to have your
body your hands whatever registered with
law enforcement because you are
considered a deadly weapon just by
yourself like without a gun or without
anything else
so I say I say no and and to kind of
hash that out a little more I say no
because a lot of people never make it
that far they don't make it to black
belt oftentimes it takes years and they
don't have that discipline they don't
they don't have the time the money the
energy whatever it is to make it to that
point and when you get to black belt
now you're just starting to learn okay
so all this other stuff you're you're
learning how to punch but after you make
your black belt you kind of revisit
everything back from the beginning and
you start to take a step back and say
okay now this is this is what we taught
you now
gonna teach you everything almost all
over again in light of being a black
belt in light of this new philosophy and
you start to really hone everything and
and and develop you know kind of a new
you go back and revisit those beginning
lessons and but most people when they're
when they're getting into it if you
don't know how to punch
if you don't know like how to form your
fists and like what knuckles to lead
with you're gonna break your hand I mean
so a lot of people they get into this
stuff and they kind of halfway know what
they're doing but there's a lot of
variables you know I mean a 90-pound
girl up against like I'm some guy that
weighs like 250 it's gonna be a you you
would have to be an upper level black
belt to make it out of that situation
because he's just too big all you gotta
do is fall on you so but I say no for
the philosophy part because you're
you're teaching somebody to react and to
kill and to hurt and injured even though
mentally you're telling them don't do
that you wanna you want to try to not do
that so which one wins out you know
that's something everybody has to weigh
in on is what wins out do you have an
alternative then I mean I guess it it
depends I mean a lot of people say guns
you know that's that's I guess one
solution if you want to defend yourself
I'm not a person who chooses to carry a
gun I don't I don't feel that need I
guess probably the biggest situation we
think about her self defenses women in
small children yeah I mean pretty much
every other scenario like most guys
figure okay I can I can pretty well
handle myself in most situations you
know either to get out of it or to walk
away or if I've got to go toe-to-toe you
know I can take care of myself
but women in small children are more of
a factor I don't know I mean I haven't
taught my own children martial arts so
far you know by the grace of God
everything's been fine people don't
generally just jump you that doesn't
just generally happen you know most
things are provoked
that's right when my dad was training in
the martial arts when you ever to go get
him get a black belt he would go to the
bar and pick a fight just so he could
use his training Wow if you're not
provoking people most people don't have
a reason to just you know walk up and
punch you in the face or kick you in the
shin or whatever so if you live a very
peaceful life don't provoke people yeah
and you know a lot of you know as far as
women it's like if you're if you're
concerned well try as much possible not
to go someplace alone you know if you're
a young lady on a college campus I won't
quit somebody at night if it's a concern
you know carry some pepper spray it's
very effective you know it's it's not
gonna hurt the person in the long run
it's gonna sting it's gonna burn but
you're not gonna hurt them and you know
hopefully you can get out of this
situation another thing is if you're a
young lady you know another example I
think of college is like a high high
probability time don't put yourself in a
situation where you're inebriated and
there's all these guys around and all of
a sudden you lose your judgment you lose
your reasoning and you are susceptible
or you do things that you regret later
or or you can't even remember what
happened you know so there's I think
there's things people can do to help
themselves it's interesting thinking of
this Nick Cannon thing you said
something kind of interesting that you
provoked a lot of the times an
engagement like that I don't know I kind
of have a hard time thinking that all of
a sudden Eminem's gonna make up
something that ridiculous
and put it out in public if there's just
zero truth to it you know I mean yeah so
I think as well when Nick Cannon's you
know trying to defend her honor and you
you sometimes can you can can actually
you know make the situation worse
because you know you're just throwing
things out there and it's like there may
be some truth to that so you probably
don't want to deal with things like that
in a public setting because you you know
you're kind of inviting that fight yeah
for this scenario with an older brother
trying to protect
the younger brother I'd say to avoid a
physical altercation as much as possible
you know that's saying on sticks and
stones may break my bones but words will
never hurt me that's a complete lie
no probably as an older sibling step in
and try to pull them away and say listen
if you ever touch my sibling again there
will be problems yeah I don't have to
like threat like actually make an actual
detailed threat but just to instill some
kind of fear some authority to kind of
you know diffuse the whole situation I
think that you did that I did that my
little brother was getting picked on and
I mean the kid was my size and he was
several years younger big kid and you
know I I heard about it and it had kept
on going and after school on the way
home like not on school property
I confronted the kid that's like look
you pick up my little brother anymore
you're gonna have me to deal with you
know and that that I think took care of
it but and after that I think they wound
up becoming friends but also see I mean
there's a different time and place a
different mindset you know I don't think
I had started training in the martial
arts yet but I was gonna defend my
little brother you know mm-hmm all right
second one your wife comes home and says
that her boss took a pass at her at work
that led to an embarrassing situation in
front of her colleagues what do you do
he's a dead man that's a really tough
situation I actually know somebody that
this has happened to and the boss really
took advantage of the woman and you know
ended up in a bad situation so yeah it's
like I first would have a talk with the
wife of that kind of a situation is even
like remotely going to happen and yeah
there's too many too many other
employers you can go work for I don't
care how good the job is to place
yourself all and terribly kind of in in
a situation that could go bad in some
times I agree that but I think I would
take different steps and the read I mean
I would talk to my wife for sure first
but I don't think I would send her to
work somewhere else because if that's
going on at that workplace you're almost
doing an injustice leaving the
situation to continue on and I mean
personally if there's multiple witnesses
it's like perfect to get that guy busted
and get him out you know not that I want
to ruin somebody's career but you that's
uncalled for and their name he legal
protections these days I would say get
rid of him you know your wife should be
able to work wherever without that kind
of pressure get rid of that guy he's the
one that needs to reevaluate his career
it sounds like a call to kind of think
sit down and think things through have
conversations not just be angry go I
mean my thought was we're gonna retire
cuz we're suing and yeah but yeah the
first thing on my mind was to have a
little talk with him but then it's like
what happy you can get in trouble for
getting countersuit and all that you
know if you're like threatening somebody
like that you tell you yeah I think
you're better off saying less in that in
a corporate you know workplace situation
and let HR take care of it the alarm
goes off in your home one night and as
you go downstairs to check it out you
run into the perp you are standing
between him and the door what do you do
you grab the nearest Golf Club baseball
bat I
well--that's somebody is inside of your
home I mean I feel it duty to protect my
family yeah I mean I think you would
react to whatever you could at that
situation because you know they're
scared to something could go bad if they
have a weapon you know they don't want
to get caught so in the wake of that
that could be a very dangerous situation
so you know you
I think you'd want to react quickly in
that situation you're gonna set of
options because you're not like give me
one second the cops will be here in any
minute right right what can you do
except fight or something yeah I think
most people you know they don't probably
want to get into an altercation
they don't want something terrible to
happen so I think if you draft quickly
as well
that may scare them off and you know
allow them to exit but yeah if I was in
between the door and this person I would
quickly go to you know something in the
room that you could take that would help
defend yourself I used to sleep with a
staff next in the room off that way if I
hadn't I mean no it's a long staff to
use in martial arts is my their custom
they're supposed to be two inches taller
than you are so I had mine I'd keep it
by the door if not that I had a sword I
used to keep nearby my mom keeps a maybe
I shouldn't put that on glass but she
keeps a machete in the house I would say
that's the weapon I have in my own is a
machete and I'm baseball bat I know I
don't I don't keep either anymore well I
don't need that I did have it like under
my bed or something but now it's just
wherever wherever happened at the beach
I think location plays a role as well
we're more in kind of like a country
setting yeah
and compared to more urban where you
know there's more higher rates of crime
my brother had a teacher in college he
was a biology teacher and he would go
down to South America and go on these
biology trips and they were in a boat in
the Amazon and they were just floating
along and all of a sudden some natives
jumped out of the water into the boat
stuck the guy through in the front and
the guy grabbed a machete I think that
was close to war and had to run the guy
through and then push him over the top
and he said it literally happened so
fast he it's not like he sad thought
about the ramifications of what was
happening and he came home and had to
have years of therapy I mean he was he
couldn't sleep there's PSD oh yeah he
told my brother's classes well I think
one of the first few classes that he
actually told and I mean it was 15 20
years since it had happened and the guy
was still dealing with the aftermath of
that so yeah I think this is one of
these situations where you just don't
want ever to have to go through that
kind of an experience and you know to
have to defend yourself like that and
especially if you get into some physical
altercation it's it's bad right so it
seems like there's there's two groups
there's one where you kind of have time
to process and thing
plan when you say you know when the
Bible instructs never to avenge yourself
that's like that's something thought out
plans systematic like I'm going to do
this this and this to this person saying
maybe you shouldn't do that versus
somewhere it's something where you need
to respond and react in that second that
split-second I feel very protective over
children mm-hmm
you know if somebody was trying to harm
my kids you know I think there's
something that would just boil my blood
like pretty quickly so it's hard to say
how it would react in that situation
naturally I'm a lover not a fighter
and so I would hopefully want to - you
know lovingly disarm the situation but
in in that case where if somebody was
trying to hurt my child I think they
would I turn into Papa Bear do we have
any examples in the Bible where somebody
was defending themselves I mean Jesus
we're always a cross never defended
himself I mean Paul publicly defended
his honor I can't remember which one of
the the books where they were kind of
claiming that he was like wrongfully
taking money I think it was I can't
remember I'd rather look this up but you
know he was kind of setting the record
straight he's never done anything wrong
and so he had to publicly set the record
straight know when people were trying to
tarnish his reputation what about self
defense like somebody's trying to take
your wife and I mean Samson you know
check out thousand people good job on it
spirit of god came over and that's a big
difference though because in a lot of
those situations you you mentioned the
key point in that is you know just
before did Samson did something amazing
this is and the Spirit of the Lord you
know there's there's all kinds of it's
interesting there's a lot of I guess
biblical perspective on both sides you
know it says that Abraham had 400 men in
his household trained for war you know
he went and rescued lot when David took
out the the bear it says right before
that the Spirit of the Lord came upon
David and he rent the bear part you know
so you
you know what David killed Goliath yeah
and he was defending the honor of his
his God and his people and you know so
yeah and I mean he carried that head
around I mean yeah top that Henderson he
literally went around with like a trophy
like here's his head yeah everybody said
well it's gnarly like there there's some
stories like I can't I have to jump over
those kind of things when I read them to
my kids cuz it's like how do you explain
that
it's it's tricky now though because then
you're dealing with a time of you know
God inspired me to do this and now if
you're walking around and saying what
God told me to off this guy you know I
mean we're talking about a different
kind of situation it doesn't quite work
the same way now as it did then I know
so was it the the spirit lead David to
kill Goliath or what did he just have
enough faith like my God's big I can
take I can handle this I I think in in
specifically David's situation when he
got into that altercation
what's amazing is he had the faith that
was literally like you know when he's
like oh you a you a dog and my dog that
you're coming to me with your sticks and
your stone's you know and he's like yeah
and then he starts cursing him in his
gods and even it says no I come to you
in the Living God like the name of the
Lord of hell yeah it's like all of a
sudden man you are not fighting me
you're picking a fight with God and God
honored that feel like the god of the
New Testament is a lot more discrete
than the God of the Old Testament that
doesn't mean he still doesn't look up to
his people he does think of all of the
Apostles they got into situations where
I mean the average person would just be
like are you kidding me let's go to war
but as in prison what a God do rescued
them and they just walked out of the
prison gates feel like God will come
through and it doesn't always have to be
in a grand spirit a grand supernatural
way it could also be with our fellow
peers but it'll be done in a way at the
at the end of the day will glorify him
with was it uh Elijah where he led like
a hundred and eighty
thousand soldiers or whatever into
Samaria they're like what do we do with
them you know did we smite them do we
smite them you know king of Israel was
like ready to offer him awesome and
they're just like no feom and giving
them water and let him go you know and
that seems kind of contrary to an Old
Testament time but that's a rad story it
is what did that do for the end result
they never came in troubled Israel again
it said so I think where there's two
roads how you could handle the situation
there's enough examples of listen if you
really do heed the advice like like
Jesus gave or like the Bible and you
know love your enemies do good to those
that hate you and and are spitefully you
know doing evil against you like the
result I think will be more lasting if
they never ever came after them again
after that it's situation you know that
would be I think of a very wise approach
for sure at the end of the day I hope
M&M doesn't respond to Nick's cannon
Nick Cannon's diss tracks and that these
two resolve their beef beef outside of
the public eye and they just come
together and just you know apologize and
kind of let it go 10 years is a long
time to be to be harboring this it takes
a lot of energy to harbor hatred and
when you kind of keep that alive I mean
look at the result of what happened a
Tupac and Biggie Smalls right I mean I
just got fueled and fueled and fueled
until like people died so in this kind
of a situation I think if you're wanting
to learn something from this the fastest
way to resolve it is a with forgiveness
and love and but but by all means I mean
that doesn't mean ignore the issue I
mean you should go to someone and say
hey you know you said something ill
against my wife or whatever like this I
don't agree with that is there a way
that we can resolve this and get it past
it I think that'd be the best way to
deal with it
and then of course if there just
continues to be public shaming I think
it's I think it's okay for you to
publicly make a statement like you said
you know I make a rebuttal or something
like that
and just talk about it in that way but
that would probably be a last resort and
then if that doesn't work out call
cousin Vinnie no
personally I'd probably just not respond
I mean because I had to learn that I
mean in junior high I mean like I picked
on a lot
and the more you let people you know
when they throw stuff at you if they
want a reaction right you give him that
reaction they're gonna keep doing it I'm
just like I don't do this with my
children right now yeah how about a flag
keep telling my son she wants you to get
upset yes if you give her a hug it would
be done I'm saying what if the response
is you know good and chill and either
yeah
yeah that's going the extra-mile if you
don't if you know if you if you're not
ready for that if you at least just back
off and just don't just don't do
anything I mean what are they gonna do
they can keep saying stuff but
eventually if they don't get a response
there's gonna be like this mmm not going
anywhere
well thank you guys so much for joining
in this discussion and thank you so much
for watching every single Friday you're
here and you're watching and you're
supporting we really appreciate you and
we'd love to hear what you think about
this topic leave it down in the comments
section below and while you're there
check out our website little light
studios that TV do we have any deals
available not right now but I should
have put in a plug if you want to learn
more about the martial arts topic we
actually have a video it's on our
YouTube channel for free it's called the
dragon revealed an old Chinese proverb
says it is better to light one candle
than to curse the darkness today there
is a growing infatuation with the
spiritual practices of the Far East dark
secrets kept hidden and buried with pain
the teachings of the Masters for nearly
two thousand years known only amongst
those who practice such art until today
who are the masters gurus and sensei's
which founded these mystical arts how
did these men develop such extraordinary
skills powers and abilities and from
whence came their inspiration where
these arts originally designed merely of
self-defense and healing or is there
something elusive and much darker
working behind the scenes is it possible
to divorce these Eastern art forms from
their spiritual groups is there a hidden
purpose behind a move to join these
ancient religious practices with the
Christian faith witness the journey of
one man's life on his quest for truth a
life of more than twenty four years
training in traditional martial arts
energy work and Chinese medicine follow
his path as a student in these mystical
art forms from beginner to black belt
from novice to fifth Dan and a high
level discipline in kung fu Tai Chi and
Chinese Qigong see how the God of the
Bible transformed his heart from a path
of self-destruction and brought him into
his marvelous light learn why we are now
witnessing a worldwide flood of Eastern
mysticism and occult philosophies is
there a reason why these ones ancient
religious practices are now being so
widely accepted and portrayed in today's
movies video games magazines and secular
as well as Christian literature
[Music]
what's on your t-shirt making your line
exposing darkness we got this and a lot
of other cool t-shirts pray for your
haters that be doing it for this one
single cents
check out those shirts that really helps
support us it's a good way to you know
break the ice when you want to wait and
witness to somebody so and there's
always patreon you guys can check out
that we got a lot of cool perks on there
you get early access you even get some
behind-the-scenes stuff you're gonna see
what things we talk about them you know
that I release to the public but check
us out it's a way to support our work in
that we thank you so much for tuning in
yeah and we will see you guys next week
on LED live
[Music]